is God in obedience to God now is it
easy no if it were easy why would you
need divine power we need the power of
God to forgive those who hurt us we need
the power of God to forgive the enemy we
need God's power because sometimes the
pain can be so great we attempted to
conclude I cannot forgive this crime
against me there's no such saying
because the greatest crime is not what
your ex-husband did to you the greatest
crime is what your sins have done to God
that's the greatest crime that led to
Calvary and so we ask God for the power
right now father why not being abused
give me the power to pray so that abuser
not to endorse this or her behavior to
pray that somehow you will not allow me
to have satanic feelings regarding this
person but at your spirit must somehow
reach that person Christ came to die for
people who did not like him read Romans
5 a six to eight whatever will be while
we were enemies why we were without
strength Christ dies with us
and so we pray for any because that's
what God told us to do and our highest
motivation for living is to be God
that's you and me we love it
wow that is definitely powerful
um there's a certain humility that that
is with that prayer that we have to
definitely pray for a spiritual strength
for that and there's a healing that
comes along with it as you mentioned
absolutely
um yeah so the part of our healing
process and for our mental health is to
to pray for our enemies
using forgiveness is divine behavior and
human beings are called to behave in a
Divine way to do that you must have
Divine help how can a sinner behave in a
Divine way but that's what God calls
upon us to behave the way I behave look
at Christ on the cross he hates that we
assist God that's what makes the true
Christians so different you know Jesus
Christ when he preached and he lived his
life people will say from time to time
what manner of man is this what kind of
man is this that you spit in his face
and he takes it they punch him in his
face he took it what kind of man is this
because he used a Heavenly mindset and
we are required to use that same mindset
so when someone cuts us off on the road
right of course you pray for the person
okay amen
so our next question is
um based on
first tests
means 5 17 that says to pray so what
does that really mean to pray without
ceasing you may have touched on this a
little bit before but if you can expand
that yeah
the second Corinth a second
Thessalonians 5 first Thessalonians 5 17
for the last season it means exactly
that it's not a symbolic text it's a
literal text it doesn't say needle
without ceasing or close your eyes
without ceasing always keep your mind in
heaven now listen to Paul the same
writer he says something in Colossians 3
verses 1 and 2. if he then be risen with
Christ see those things which are above
where Christ sit on the right hand of
God or the father set your obsectional
things above now is your Reflections are
set on things above that's where your
mind will be Jesus said in Matthew 6 21
for where your treasure is they really
are happy also and so when your mind is
in heaven and you always interacting
with Heaven you are in a state of
constant prayer not a specific bless
this food but your mind is always
interacting with God why because what's
important to you is in heaven not on the
earth and so you always in tune and in
touch
you are always in a state of Prayer by
constant communication with Heaven
because your most precious assets are in
heaven not on the earth now if they're
on the earth your mind will be always on
the Earth
remember what Christ said where your
treasure is where which is important to
you is located that's where your mind
will be pray though ceasing keep your
mind in heaven keep it there but you can
only do that if you realize that the
most important things are the spiritual
things and that's where you put your
mind in heaven
we must learn to chat with God you know
we chat online with all sorts of people
friends and strangers we chat online
chat with God literally there's an
online connection between Heaven and
Earth called Jesus Christ trapped with
God about every single thing just chat
with God you're in traffic telling me
you're in traffic
you know you whatever you're you're in
the stone it is a long queue because
it's Thanksgiving and you can't check
out your groceries tell him chat with
God about everything it is a discipline
that has to be practiced or it becomes
instinct
oh okay thank you for that and it's like
the the Heavenly Wi-Fi always has to be
connected yes
yes yeah and me I'm being raised the
Catholic I kind of struggled with that
chat with God because I was just so used
to more formal prayers and yeah my
prayers were not structured the the
correct way but thank you for that
encouragement you're welcome I was also
raised Catholic
so my final question for you today is um
how do we reconcile Faith obedience and
prayer what is a conception good
question let me pray again father as we
continue please give us all of us wisdom
and clear understanding in Jesus name I
pray amen how do you reconcile season
obedience with prayer let us go to
Proverbs 28 we'll read verse 9. we
looked at obedience Proverbs 28 verse 9.
and whoever has it can read it but
there's Tanisha my dear friend there
Proverbs 28 verse 9.
he that
turneth away has anyone found it
whoever finds you to read it
Proverbs 28 verse 9 verse 9 UM turneth
away his ear from here
his prayer shall be an Abomination now
this is this is on you to a deliberate
Behavior not someone who's unaware an
ignorant uninformed unenlightenment this
is deliberate willful disregard of God's
review realm and the word law in the
Bible sometimes be the reveal will of
God from Genesis revelation
he who turns away this is not accidental
this is willful denial disregard even
his prayer shall be what and about now
and Abomination is serious business
the Bible has sins and it has
Abominations
both will get you lost if you're not
confessed
but one is more intense than the other
an abomination
is a more intense form of Syria and the
highest abomination in the Bible I
believe is idolatry where you place God
in your life with somebody else an
Abomination is something God absolutely
despises it it makes him puke
that's an Abomination and the Bible says
Those Who willfully deliberately turn
away their ears from hearing the
instructions of God's word when they
pray they pray just upsets God's time
even his prayer
I'm saying that to say obedience to God
insofar as the praying the praying
person is enlightened is absolutely
essential Faith well without faith we're
telling God I don't believe you and
that's an insult to God
faith is the expression of trust in thus
said the Lord faith is simply taking God
at his word God does not reward doubt he
rewards faith
safe must let's go to let's go to Mark
chapter 11. you got an idea what I'm
trying to say in mark 11.
let's read verse 23 of Mark 11.
the time was passed so quickly it's
already 13 minutes to three Mark 11 read
my sister verse 23. this is Jesus
speaking
yes and it says um for verily I say unto
you that whatsoever shall see onto this
mountain without removed and be thou
cast into the sea and shall not doubt in
him stop stop and shall not doubt that's
essential shall not doubt the verses
they shall only doubt a little shall not
doubt in his heart keep reading foreign
but shall believe that those things
which he saith shall come to pass he
shall
have what soever
he said no some people take that first
all by itself and say okay I believe why
did I get it it must also go along with
he that turns away his ear from hearing
the law of Proverbs 28 verse 9 it must
go along with Psalm 66 verse 18. if I
regard iniquity in my heart the Lord
will not hear me in other words there's
something wrong in me I know it's there
I keep doing it then I want God to
answer my prayers or I see sin somewhere
and I approve of it God doesn't like
that so the other conditions associated
with praying to praying and getting your
prayer answered but we're focusing on
belief Faith the absence of Faith
Constitution insult to God in the sense
that I'm saying I'm telling God I do not
believe what you said I'm saying that to
someone who said let me be like and
there was life and I'm telling him I
don't believe your word despite all that
your word did in Genesis 1. there must
be faith faith in the word of God not
faith is not believing God will do what
I say that's how some of us interpret
faith faith is believing that God will
do what I say that's not faith that is
high-class presumption faith is
believing God will do what he says he'll
do not that God will do what I say
that's not faith that is suicidal
presumption faith is believing God will
do what he has said what he has said is
in here not in here it's here now and so
when we pray must pray in faith so Jesus
said If You Shall Believe and not doubt
do not doubt but remember the other
conditions for answer query but safe is
absolutely essential because whatsoever
is not a faith is sin but your faith
must be intelligent without there's no
faith without the word of God so your
faith must be based on that said the
Lord faith is not disconnected from the
word of God it's impossible
remove God's word no one can exercise
Faith so the faith required when we're
praying must mean that somehow our
prayers are based on thus set the Lord
in so far as we can you know I need to
say it very clearly in all that we do we
cannot ignore the Bible
you want feelings we want emotions we
want this experience and we have the
simple just set the Lord there is no
Crystal experience that justifies to
ignoring God's word because the entire
universe was made by God's word and the
new heaven the new Earth will be made by
God's word so faith is connected to
God's word it cannot exist without the
word of God faith is believing God will
do what he has said that he will do not
that he will do what I see that's not
Faith that's presumption there must be
Faith there must be obedience God does
not bless Disobedience he does not bless
doubt go to Acts chapter 8 my good
sister we read one more verse on this
subject Acts chapter 8
let's read from verse 36 this is Philip
and the Ethiopian eunuch a very popular
well-known story read from verse 36 of
Acts chapter 8.
you have that
with me for a second
from verse 37
36 sorry 36 and 37.
and as they okay 36 and 37 and it says
and as they went went on their way
and the eunuch said see
and Philip said if thou believe this
with
with all the fine heart yes no that's a
critical thing
answered and said I believe that Christ
is the Son of God okay and so here in
this verse there must be total surrender
of the heart in Belize and Jesus said if
you believe and will not doubt just do
not doubt now go to James chapter one
let's read verse 5.
okay
we're five to seven of James chapter one
James chapter one verses five to seven
five
okay yes so it says if any of you lack
wisdom let him ask of God that give it
to all men liberally and a breed is not
and it shall be given him yes but let
him ask him Faith nothing wavering false
right there nothing wavering don't doubt
don't doubt nothing Waverly just like
Mark 11 23 and shall not doubt just like
Acts chapter 8 verse 37 believeth your
whole heart shall nothing wavering James
chapter 1 verse nothing wavering why
because you're trusting the word of God
and so successful prayer requires faith
that cannot be shaken in the word of God
not in you in God's word so we see the
role of obedience and faith in prayer
and you cannot separate obedience from
Satan because the obedience we need is
The Obedience of faith
or The Obedience we should practice is
The Obedience of Faith you cannot
separate Faith from the word of God you
cannot separate Faith from obedience
next question
you see when we pray this should be
spiritual it's almost like a fabric
there are three of them
where they have to go together yes
prayer is an experience with God not
just an opportunity to go to the Divine
ATM and get some cash it is an
experience with God protects you into
the very presence of God whether you
want something or not and we must always
want more grace we must always want more
faith praying sometimes God withholds
things from us that we may pray and pray
and pray because he hasn't seen us for a
long time and so he wants us to come to
him so he withholds some things from us
so that we can pray and pray and pray
praying is not simply an Avenue of
asking it is an opportunity to
fellowship with God to hang out with God
to use a common expression that's what
prayer essential is
but we use it just to us give me this
give me this give me that give me give
me give me attitude no prayer is
recognizing that I am in the presence of
God and I love to be in God's presence
that's why I'm always praying whether I
want something or not
Every Act is judged by the motives
Christ's object lesson Spirit 3 16
paragraph two what's your motive for
praying to get things out of God
the devil can give you things
all right next question so powerful so I
will go ahead and hand it over to Sister
Anisha she's going to take some of the
Open Floor questions that we've gotten
thank you before we take open floor
questions I wanted to go back to this
kind cometh not out with my prayer and
fasting can we do that absolutely in
fact
let me just add that section that
question that he actually did not make
it on the stream oh okay go ahead go
ahead no no no so I would be grateful if
you can definitely go back to that thank
you now Jesus told the disciples in Mark
chapter 9 verse 28 this guy this this
kind cometh not for but by prayer and
fasting like what does it mean by this
kind now the Greek word for kind is Geno
on which we have Gene and genome and
genetics
it means uh it can mean a nation it can
mean a group it can mean it just means a
special kind
Jesus is saying this kind of demon
cannot go unless this praying fasting
now we must keep in mind some demons are
more powerful than others
let me say it again some demons are more
powerful than others go to Luke chapter
11 very quickly and if we go over uh
three o'clock it's okay with me let's go
to Luke 11 we'll read verse 24-26 I just
said some demons are more powerful than
others even as some angels are more
powerful than others Gabriel being the
heights Luke 11 verse 24 when the
unclean spirit is gone out of a man he
wonders through Dry places seeking rest
and finding none he's safe I will return
unto my heart from whence I came when he
cometh he finally says swept them
garnish then go see and take it to him
seven other Spirits now what the next
few words more wicked more wicked than
himself now we pause and we think the
verse is telling us clearly some demons
are more wicked and more powerful or
more equipped to do wickedness than
other demons now Ella white rights in
Child Guidance page 408 paragraph one
in Temperance
is something not easily conquered the
demon of the temperance is not easily
conquered it is of giant strife and not
easily overcome the demon of
intemperance she says is of giant
strength and not easily conquered now
she writes in in Heavenly Places page
194 paragraph three
in Temperance lies are the foundation of
all the moral evils known to man Christ
began the Redemption of the rescue just
where the ruin began administ fell on
appetite lack of temperance that's where
Christ began the fight to redeem Mankind
in the area of intembrance
I'm saying that to say that demon that
terrorized that boy must have been a
strong demon and so Jesus said that kind
of demon if you look at what the demon
did to the ball if you add the details
from Mark chapter 9 Luke chapter 9 and
Matthew chapter 17 the demon would tear
the boy that was Heavenly convulsion he
would fall on the ground for me he would
bruise him meaning physical damage you
know he would cast him into the fire
cast him in the water trying literally
to kill him now this demon did Terrible
Things to that boy he would form a
demand he was described by the father
his mind was gone all of that by a demon
and Jesus says look that kind of even it
is prayer and fasting that those demons
respect and when someone who does the
praying and fasting fervently and
commands them to leave their league but
you can't come to that kind of demon you
know with just a casual would you please
leave because the Bible says you want to
leave that does not work so Jesus wants
us to understand there are some demonic
addition some demonic activity that
requires serious spiritual preparation
and that particular demon that
terrorized that boy was of such power
that Jesus said look he also told them
your unbelief was one reason why you
couldn't cast him out
but
there has to be prayer fasting plus
Faith so that you go in the strength of
Jesus Christ and Christ was able to
Castle the demon but those disciples
should have been but while Christ was in
the mount with Peter James and John the
other nine were complaining they were
jealous they were envious and they
fought among themselves they were
spiritually unable to deal with this
demonic Presence by the way let me say
something I said on one of our programs
long time ago there's no such thing in
the Adventist Church a Deliverance
Ministry don't go looking for demons to
cast out please do not do that I'm not
saying to be afraid of Lucifer a Satan
no no no you're a child of God you're
back to my God but even Christ in the
Christ trials at page 190 paragraph five
the Bible said Christ had been warned
not to enter into argument with Satan
God warned him in your Humanity don't
get into the back and forth with the
devil if it's not me don't do that and I
always said Christ recognized him but
was not provoked to enter into
University with them his interaction
with the devil were matters of necessity
he had to act and he acted there are
some Adventists who have this uh what's
called Deliverance Ministry
there is no such thing
don't go looking for the devil Jesus did
not go to the Wilderness looking for the
Devil the devil knew he'd go there and
went after him
prayer and fasting is essential in our
conflict with the Devil
absolutely essential but keep in mind
some demons are more ferocious and
stronger and more frightening than
others this one was apparently a
terrible demon and Jesus said plus your
unbelief prayer and fasting is necessary
for this kind of wicked demon to be cast
out
powerful powerful thank you for giving
us not only the etymology of that word
kind Elder scheme and also building the
context around uh the powers that we
wrestle with that there are there are
demons that are more wicked than the one
yes on the other side there are angels
more powerful than other angels
go sell that system they are Gabriel is
the highest Angel before he fell Lucifer
was the highest Angel not every angel
can go right up to the throne of God he
used if it could you see he was the
anointed cherub I have set this so help
my God other Angels couldn't do that no
one complained but that's the system God
had a hierarchy there's a high priest on
the Levi the leaf ripe under no
circumstances could enter the most holy
place the hyper is good or the most on
their day of a tournament and so there's
the levels of power in the good system
the levels of weakness in the evil
system some demons have more power to do
evil than other demons they're all bad
but worse than others and the worst of
all of course is Satan himself
amen Amen brother Carlton Graham said
new powerful insight and uh new insight
powerful study praise God praise God
there are many others here that have
been commenting in the chat brother
Kelly Edwards he actually preached today
he too has affirmed the word that you've
been speaking and the Protestant here on
YouTube has said faith is so much easier
when the word is within us yes yes
no word no faith
amen amen so the skeet I mean I know we
are past three o'clock
you but just give me a heads up when you
are ready to go is there another
question connected to this presentation
there is there is let's have it let's
have
this comes from Advent family missions
Nigeria Africa oh okay yes what do you
have to say about praying violently in
order for God to hear you is it possible
to yell at God when he isn't answering
prayer
it doesn't heard that question before
it's interesting
you cannot write specific rules for how
a person should interact with God in a
private session for instance if you read
uh First Corinthians 14 prayerfully
there is this possibility of speaking in
a tongue to God that no one else
understand but in your closet at home
not in a public setting in a public
setting there must be interpretation the
Bible is very clear but there's the
possibility of speaking to God in a
certain way privately that no one else
understands now
I was talking to someone a few years ago
the person said she had been praying and
praying and praying and then once she
walked out
in the open air and just screamed you
know to the god to fix the situation she
screamed not disrespectful it was a cry
of she screamed to God not so much at
God she's praying to God and that was
her individual interaction with God she
was she was bursting with frustration
she screamed to God I can't tell someone
you can't raise your voice I'm simply
saying never be disrespectful to God but
God understands frustration God
understands the rent is due tomorrow or
I'll be evicted with my three children
it is February in Michigan 25 degrees
below zero and I'll be evicted where are
you and the person will scream God God
is a father he understands them
of course screaming can be a modus
operandi with dinner with God but there
may be a point where you are so you're
so bursting with whatever that you may
have to shout and stream it's an
individual thing
I cannot condemn it but always remember
God deserves respect and reference but I
can't legislate to someone what decibel
level The Voice should have when he or
she is speaking to God but you may come
to the point where you need to just yeah
scream
I Cried unto the Lord with my voice that
doesn't sound like a whisper
God understands loud speaking Jesus
shouted when he told Lazarus come
forward when he comes to second time he
shout when God made the world he didn't
whisper
so they maybe need us on the age Vision
on the individual level this is not
Church manual recommendation on the
individual level too he said God where
are you
he understands
amen amen
now over skeet we have a couple um open
form questions that are not in keeping
with the theme and there's one other
request I would have the second the
third question we asked
uh we weren't able to get an answer
recorded okay is it okay all right
what's that question
excuse me it was not the
third question I think it was fourth
whatever it is sometimes we find
ourselves praying a long time for a
situation how do we determine if we are
praying outside of God's will or if he
desires us to persist in prayer and I'll
read James Chapter 4 verses 3 and 4 for
content
foreign
States
ye acts and receive not because he acts
amiss that ye may consume it upon your
lust the adulterers and adulteresses
know ye not that the Friendship of the
world is enmity with God whosoever
therefore will be a friend of the world
is an enemy of God so just for
repetition emphasis how do we determine
if we are praying outside of God's will
or if he desires us to persist in prayer
as a general rule God always wants this
persist in prayer whatever we're praying
about he always wants us to persist in
prayer I believe I said earlier one we
have to ask the question this thing I'm
praying about is the anything about it
that is inconsistent with the Bible two
this thing I'm praying about is the
anything about it that's inconsistent
more specifically with the Ten
Commandments which represent the whole
duty of man will this request if granted
compromise the exercise of my duty which
is the Ten Commandments of God expressed
from the heart I also said uh is this
some area of God's will some aspect of
God's will which I already know that I
do not carry out if that's the case it's
unlikely God will continue to reveal
other aspects of his will it will only
encourage us to be similarly uh
irresponsible let me say it again
differently if God is revealed A and B
to me and I am irresponsible and not
obeying A and B why should God c and d
That's where God functions and so you
must search the line is this some
revealed will that I am not complying
with let me take care of that then the
Lord may open the way to answer our
prayers so is this something I need to
be doing that I'm not doing a part of
God's will is this request biblical is
it consistent with the Ten Commandments
of God and then the two of the questions
you're going to ask one if this is
granted with a glorify God
you must be able to say yes or no if it
is granted will it glorify God too if it
is granted will it be a blessing to
others
and glorifying God and being a blessing
to others are the only two motivations I
should drive us as Extreme as that may
sound they are the only in historical
sketch of speech 285 paragraph four
alawite writes every youth should be
impressed with the fact that he's not
his own that his strength his time his
talents belong to God it should be his
chief purpose in life to glorify God and
to do good his fellow man case Clause
that's it the two driving motivations
are glorifying God being a blessing to
your fellow man and so the question has
to be if God grants me this how will he
be glorified or more differently what's
in this for God
I know what's there for me what's in
this for God and there is no request you
and I should make that does not include
what's in this for God and secondarily
how will others be blessed because the
Ten Commandments are serve for God loved
your fellow man and that's it there's in
the third category and so one am I
fulfilling other aspects of God's will I
already know two
is this contrary to the Bible if not
proceed is it contrary to the Ten
Commandments if not proceed can God be
blessed proceed can God be honored
proceed can others be less perceived
believing that God will answer your
prayer and be persistent in prayer if
nothing about this thing violates God's
will God's law does not disgrace God
will not be a curse to others as far as
you can see because your vision is
limited pursue with the confidence that
you're praying according to God's word
but remember a quotation I gave review
and Herald April 30 1889 paragraph seven
if you find your way hard and wholesome
you may know you love it the right way
if nothing seems to be working out
you've done these other checks nothing
is working out you're probably the wrong
way and God wants you to realize
but don't give up too quickly then say
God will answer it
Daniel Prayed three weeks God heard him
on day one and had the answer on day one
but he had to pray three weeks
amen amen
all right
all right so I'll just keep I'm going to
leave it up to you I there may I think
there was one question tangentially
related to prayer but I from my
understanding
the rest of the questions I do not think
uh align
foreign
so let's not go to something tangential
but you said there's something that
seems related to pray
the question comes again from Advent
family missions it is what is the
difference between a good idea not
necessarily sinful and God's will
okay okay interesting a good idea and
God's will the Bible says there is a way
of the sea myth write down to a man but
the end thereof are the ways of death
Proverbs 14 12. a good idea it seems
good again the test must be thus said
the Lord there is no circumstance that
that that is uh exempt from being
exposed to this the standard of what's
right and wrong you bring that good idea
to the word of God
and more specifically to the Ten
Commandments you apply the two
principles how will this good idea
glorify God how will this good idea
bless my fellow man is there any degree
of Self in this good idea will glory
come to me if this good idea comes to
reality or to fruition is it consistent
with the word of God is it consistent
more specifically with the Ten
Commandments will God be glorified we
let us be blessed that's how you feel
when you judge the goodness of this good
idea
because there is a way that seemeth
right notice it seems right
but it seems right to someone with a
with a sinful mind it seems right but it
is wrong all the ways of a man are right
in his own eyes the final judge must be
God speaking through his word
so bring all good ideas
to the searching light of thus said the
Lord
amen amen and Elder skeet I I believe
there's one question from our audience
and I believe this is likely in line
with our topic but I don't want to punch
on your time
go on go on thank you all right so
Sister Sister
Henry you can ask your question
thank you um Denisha um
other ski one good question so uh I've
been to many
um well I've heard of many and been to
many prayer conferences where it's
seemingly that people are
trying to teach others how to pray and
there are people who sometimes in those
conferences walk away saying that day
they're kind of intimidated especially
to pray in public it's a special way we
should teach people I know the Bible
says I mean teach us how to pray but
it's just special way we should be
praying that there are certain words
that we should be using because just
seeing that sometimes the words are so
fancy and colorful like others
especially those who are just um coming
into the church as new Believers and
kind of intimidated
well there's nothing wrong with teaching
people to pray in Luke chapter 11. and
it came to pass that as he was praying
in a certain place when he ceased one of
the disciples said Lord teach us to pray
as John also taught the disciples Luke
11 I think verse 1. and so teaching
people to pray that's absolutely fine
but the Bible also says growing grace
second Thessalonians 3 verse 18. people
learned a new conflict has to learn how
to pray yes there's there's a science of
prayer there's a science of self it's
there's a way to pray but praying is
essentially the honest expression of the
contents of the heart of God whose
Spirit God knows you just got baptized
last week he knows your life has been
spent in whatever the world where you
had no exposure to him he knows all
these things he sees your heart before
you speak and according to Romans
chapter 8 26 27 the holy ghost jumps in
there and makes intercessions for us
when we do not know what to say and so
you never left hanging if you think you
do not know how to pray you just tell
God that the same in where you tell
someone else I don't know how to pray as
I said earlier tell God I do not know
how to pray it but there are no specific
words you have to heal Jesus said when
you pray say our father you pray to the
father Yes you pray in the name of Jesus
John 14 12 and 13. you pray through the
spirit Romans 8 26 and 27 so you pray in
the name of Jesus Christ why because
without his sacrifice the father can do
nothing for you not that he doesn't want
to and wouldn't like to without the sack
because of sin the sacrifice of Christ
becomes the reason why the father can
give you or me the smallest or the
biggest blessing and so we pray in the
name of Jesus Christ acknowledging who
Christ is he's God his man Creator
savior live the sinless life voluntarily
give his life raise himself from the
dead he's interceding now we pray in his
name with a consciousness of all that he
stood for and all that he is we pray to
the father because the father is the
highest Authority in the Heavenly family
and we pray through the spirit because
he's both the spirit of the father and
of the son and so he's also an
interceding agency when the children of
God pray and so yes there is a way to
pray in to God the father in the name of
Jesus Through the spirit but also pray
biblically my dear sister what do I mean
by that
if you were sick
you praying for healing for yourself
somebody else
you may say to God father you said in
your word if thou will diligently
hearten unto the voice of the love thy
God and will do that which is right in
his sight you quote uh Exodus 15 26 I
will put none of these diseases upon you
of course you've got conditions to
fulfill and so you pray quoting the word
of God you say to God father you said
bring you all the tithered to the
storehouse I will bless you in such a
degree you will not have room to receive
it have returned it father now keep your
word that's praying biblically by
reminding God this is what you said
that's well not just one way to pray
that shall always be the way we pray in
connection with the word of God because
I said earlier God is obligated to his
word he will never deny his word never
say step his word in all your praying as
much as possible bring God's word to him
not to Corner God or to Trap God but to
say father my hope is in thus said the
Lord and I thank you you never disregard
your work so yes you but the more you
pray the better you become a prey and I
hate to use the word better or skillful
but the more you pray the more easily
you pray not the less you feel the need
of God the more easily the exercise of
praying comes to you because you're
learning to pray but the power of
praying is the word of God in your
prayer let me say that again
I must always add God's word no matter
what the circumstances the power of
prayer is not only an honest heart but
it's also the involvement of God's word
in your praying all right that's my
response
but pray as often as possible and the
spirit will teach you how to pray in
addition to any other thing you may read
also read
um the book steps of Christ the chapter
the privilege of prayer read that book
that everyone has an entire book called
prayer try to get it and read it
amen amen thank you so much for
answering that question Elder skeet and
I'm I'm going to make this the last
question all right
uh this question is okay so I'll just
read it good afternoon and happy Sabbath
can you ex can you please explain the ax
patch to explain the concept of Prayer
Warriors as we use this term in church
which gives the impression that prayer
warriors and it's in quotes have a
greater ability to pray than those that
are not prayer warriors uh this appears
to be a turmer tool of the devil that
discourages individuals from praying
yeah yeah this expression for a Warriors
came into the church a few decades ago
I have no problem with the expression
pray Warriors
but we have to be careful
how we allow an expression to affect our
Behavior
any there's such a thing as cause
intercessory prayer it's biblical
if you read uh if you go to First
Timothy chapter two let's read verse one
first Timothy chapter 2 verse one I
exalt therefore that first of all
supplication prayers intercessions and
giving a thanks be media for all men for
kings and for all that are in Authority
now notice what he says I exalt it for
the first of all supplications prayers
intercessions and giving your thanks be
made Paul said look pray for people
that's an accessory prayer and so we
have prayer warriors specialize in
praying for people but a prayer Warrior
cannot be seen as someone who has more
easy access to God than you do the Bible
said come through Jesus Christ you have
access to Christ the way anybody else
has now let me say this
Christ had 12 disciples
they had varying levels of closeness to
him
you study the gospels clearly that
becomes very obvious on certain special
occasions Christ only took Peter James
and John
the amount of transfiguration he took
Peter James and John when he went to get
assembly to stuff and pray and bleed
Peter James and John when he heals
jairus's daughter in Mark chapter five
he took Peter James and John for
whatever reasons known best of Christ he
did not take the other line the three
were closer to him than the other nine
of course after 12 John was the closest
so there are degrees of closeness now
I've often thought to myself if I wanted
a Biblical character to pray for me who
would I choose I'd probably choose Enoch
because absolutely she was you know
Enoch was close to God yes we all have
access but some can come closer to God
than others now I don't know if the
priorities are closer than you I cannot
say that I'm simply saying there are
some people whose prayers are just
powerful because of their relationship
with God let's take for example the
thief on the cross
well if I had to have him to pray for me
or Enoch who do you think had to choose
Enoch or Elijah or Moses or Joshua who
told the son to stand still and the sun
Stood Still you know that's the way she
was not the thief on the cross but God
saved him he had access to cry to God
through Jesus Christ and so yes there
are people whose prayers have power they
seem to almost have a gift of brain I
acknowledge that yes but let no one tell
you you cannot go directly to God as
close as you can go you go and God will
bless you because religion uh
Christianity the gospel is first and
foremost an individual thing mind
character personality Volume 2 page 423
paragraph two the gospel deals with
individuals every person will be
convicted converted for himself repent
believe obey for himself so yes you go
to God but the Bible tells us pray for
one another there are people who love to
pray it is good to ask them pray for me
prayer for me does not mean I'm helpless
personally it is I need more power more
support
Jesus told the disciples what with me he
also made they should pray with him pray
for him as he suffered they all fell
asleep if Jesus could say pray with me
and form me surely you and I can do that
but that does not invalidate the fact
you can go directly to God never give up
that privilege never not to any prayer
Warrior but those who call themselves
pray Warriors they pray for others and
That's essential in the church
intercessory prayer
amen amen thank you so much Elvis
founding on that question and and giving
that that clear explanation we truly
appreciate your time my pleasure for for
even going over and then I'll just read
one of the comments uh from YouTube
brother Dwayne uh has said
oh well in response so one of the things
you said some of us even essays are
praying with too many vain repetitions
The Lord's Prayer is a simple pattern
truly that's right of the soul and bring
all good ideas to the searching light of
the Sith we really appreciate your time
Elder skeet we really don't take it for
granted you could have been a thousand
places but you set aside your sometime
in your busy schedule to be here with us
and so we say thank you thank you thank
you my pleasure my pleasure my pleasure
my privilege really
God bless
yes Elder skeet so please give sister
sweet our regards I will I will
wonderful rest
of me okay thank you abundantly may he
restore your strength and give you
vision and energy to continue laboring
in his Vineyard
and may God bless all those who listen
let me urge you pray pray
study the word study the word and obey
the word the power comes in obedience
you can study from now the Doomsday if
you do not obey Jesus says to you in
Luke 6 46 why call ye me Lord and do not
be things which I ask or I say study the
word obey the word live a prayer life
meaning you're always talking to God no
matter what you're doing you just
talking to God casually seriously firmly
informally keep your mind always above
so that the devil has to wait until you
stop talking to God but never stop let
him wait
amen amen thank you so much Elder skeet
thank you so much may we indeed pray and
without ceasing
savior all right then well I guess while
I'm here let me just give my thanks
thank you very much sister shirelle
Pierre for asking those questions and
even adding some commentary or brother
Dwayne I'll also like that analogy of
heavenly qui-fi thank you for joining
and participating in this program this
afternoon I also extend thanks to
brother Anthony Charles who'll be
hearing him in a moment he'll be
ministering a piece on saxophone I love
the Lord many thanks as well to assist
the chorus Bishop who will be doing our
closing prayer and I thank all of you
that have joined on YouTube Facebook
Twitter twitch and zoom as well for your
presence for your questions and
commentary I pray that as a result of
this program we have been drawn closer
to God and that we will have a fresh a
refreshing of our spiritual connection
with God and we will truly pray
earnestly and fervently and I also
extend thanks
to my mom for her prayers guidance help
with the setup and most of all all glory
to God for making this possible he is
the source of our strength he is the
strength of our life as the song says
and for him we live move and have our
being so we praise God for the
opportunity to share the word of God
while it is yet day so okay I see
someone is asking how to receive a copy
of this program but you can watch the
replay on YouTube I'm unfortunately part
of it was not captured as the stream
went down but I started recording uh
hopefully I'll probably be able to maybe
combine some videos so at least a more
complete uh copy of the program will be
uploaded on YouTube so you can go to my
YouTube channel Denisha mccarchen and uh
get catch the replay
without further Ado I will play the
recording brother Anthony Charles has
graced us with I love the Lord on sex
the phone pray you're blessed
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
love her
baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
amen thank you so much for the Anthony
Charles he's just 15 years old and
praise God he's a young man using his
talents for the Lord may God continue to
bless you I also extend thanks to uh
brother Pastor Stephen bino for
co-hosting behind the scenes and sister
Stacy and brown for you know collecting
the questions from the chat and
moderating the chat as well so thank you
for co-hosting may God continue to bless
you all and thank you sister sister
Henry for that benediction we praise God
for the work he is doing and we thank
God that we can be used by him
amen I will now invite sister Charis
Bishop to do our closing prayer
okay happy Sabbath everyone good
afternoon thank you again Pastor Steve
for just being here to answering all the
questions and thank you Denisha for
organizing the Q a
okay let us pray
gracious Lord we just thank you so much
for your mercies and your grace we thank
you for just teaching us about the
importance of friend fasting Lord Regis
thank you that um it's not just to pray
and pass because of food but for things
that we need to restrain from things
that we desire so father we just thank
you and give you all the praise and all
the glory and we just thank you for this
opportunity in Jesus name amen
amen amen thank you so much sister
caress uh before we leave I would just
like to share with you all
um the next q a that we'll be doing for
the month of December we are not doing a
q a we are having a year in review but
January God willing 28th 2023 at two
o'clock P.M Eastern Standard time we'll
be having a q a with Pastor John Loma
King and his wife sister Angela Loma
King on marriage and singleness so feel
free to take a screenshot of this save
the date uh we look forward to having
you all again uh January 28th uh 2023 at
two o'clock P.M Eastern Standard Time
for Q a with Pastor John and Angela Loma
King on marriage and singleness that's
the same Zoom information same YouTube
information and so forth all right then
thank you all for joining and may God
bless you abundantly and richly thank
you brother Carlton Graham also for
being on may God bless you all and may
you have a wonderful rest of the Sabbath
day thank you and God bless